es ist eine der härtesten arbeitsplätze
der welt
einer der krassesten ort an dem ich über
ein
1,8 hektar bewegliches
us-amerikanisches hoheitsgebiet mehr ist
so im großen bereich manets vollständig
ihm und was von dir
über 5000 menschen halten alles am
laufen
wir sind eine schwimmende starten
willkommen an bord der uss george hw
bush hier gibt es knochenjob wir müssen
27 tonnen schweren flugzeugen ausweichen
traumjobs
es gibt kaum was das mehr spaß macht
und einen gemeinsamen mission
wir wissen alle worum es geht den pfeil
auszuschalten
[Musik]
stabil bush alltag auf dem
flugzeugträger
der flugzeugträger ist das schwerste
geschütz der us- nehmen
ein fast 100.000 tonnen koloss aus
metall
seine ladung
kampfflugzeuge im wert von über einer
milliarde dollar
[Musik]
und seine mission
luftunterstützung in internationalen
krisengebieten
[Musik]
darauf ist alles auf dem schiff
ausgerichtet
auf einem flugzeugträger gibt es
verschiedene jobs
der härteste von ihnen
kampfpilot
[Musik]
sie sind die stars auf dem schwimmenden
marinestützpunkt
adrenalin spaß
[Musik]
es ist zwar auch viel arbeit aber auf
jeden fall besser als an einem
schreibtisch zu sitzen
jeden tag luftangriffe zu fliegen ist
verdammt stressig
man ist stundenlang in einem winzigen
cockpit gefallen
und einem druck ausgesetzt der zehn mal
größer ist als das eigene körpergewicht
selbst in den brenzligsten situationen
müssen die piloten einen kühlen kopf
denn was sie tun entscheidet über leben
und tod
nicht jeder job hat einen so hohen
coolness-faktor
nur etwa 200 besatzungsmitglieder
steuern ein flugzeug ein großteil der
frauen und männer an bord sorgt rund um
die uhr dafür dass auf der uss bush
alles reibungslos funktioniert
90 prozent der jobs auf dem schiff
machen matrosen der navy sie sind ihr
rückgrat
der ranghöchste matrose ist command
master chiefs und philips
da ist der ganze was übrig geblieben
alle 5000 besatzungsmitglieder hören auf
sein kommando
ich bin für ihre gesundheits entwicklung
und ernährung verantwortlich
unter dem flugdeck gibt es noch 18 6
philips besucht jeden tag alle matrosen
die auf ihnen arbeiten
es gibt die männer und frauen die das
schiff am laufen halten
andere ermöglichen die kampfeinsätze und
wiederum andere kümmern sich um das
arbeitsklima
er ist berater
was werden sie heute besonders
und
erziehungsberechtigte egal ob der hund
blick eine gabel geben sie auf
das durchschnittsalter der matrosen ist
mir kommt zugute dass ich mich
hochgearbeitet habe ich weiß wie das
leben eines matrosen auf einem
kriegsschiff
[Musik]
viele der matrosen arbeiten länger als
zwölf stunden täglich und sehen manchmal
wochenlang kein tageslicht
philips will ihnen ein gefühl von
kameradschaft vermitteln doch auch die
disziplinen darf nicht fehlen das leben
auf see ist haben aber wir vergessen nie
warum wir hier sind egal ob koch
nachrichten spezialist oder einsatz wir
wissen alle worum es geht den feind
auszuscheiden
um das zu tun sind sie auf eines
angewiesen
kampfflugzeuge
die piloten müssen sich darauf verlassen
können dass die maschinen immer
flugfähig sind
darum kümmern sich die 1000
flugzeugtechniker an bord
lieutenant commander lisa klar
ich muss sicherstellen dass die
flugzeuge repariert werden damit sie die
einsätze fliegen können
ich beabsichtige die wartung von etwa
170 maschinen
jeden tag finden auf der uss bursch
mindestens 25 starts und landungen statt
bei jeder von ihnen könnte das fluc werk
verzogen werden
das salz in luft und wasser schadet den
maschinen die flugzeugtechniker suche
nach anzeichen von rust der beiden in
mehreren
dollar teuren jets zu fehlfunktionen
führen und so das leben der piloten
gefährden könnte
wir nehmen das sehr ernst
der albtraum eines jeden technikers ist
das einer der piloten nicht mehr
zurückkommt und dass ein flugzeug war an
dem er gearbeitet hat
[Musik]
das leben der piloten liegt in unseren
händen
[Musik]
nicht nur die piloten verlassen sich auf
die flugzeugtechniker auch die
verbündeten der usa
täglich müssen mindestens 55 flugzeuge
zur verfügung stehen
sonst kann das schiff seine mission
nicht erfüllen
eine maschine kaputt ist kann man nicht
einfach irgendwo ein ersatzteil kaufen
deshalb haben wir fünf bis 7000 davon
dabei
[Musik]
damit sie ihn nicht ausgehen kommt jede
woche ein versorgungsschiff vorbei
das bringt zusätzliche munition
nahrungsmittel und waffen
heute werden nicht nur ersatzteile für
die jets geliefert sondern auch bomben
bestandteile
die piloten im haar 60s york holen sie
an bord
einer von ihnen ist commander aric
austin
es gibt kaum ist das mehr spaß macht
zwei hubschrauber ziehen den nachschub
nach oben
das ist eine der hauptaufgaben der
chirurg piloten
das versorgungsschiff hat alles auf
seinem flug denkt die hubschrauber
müssen ist da nur noch abtransportieren
das ist der effektivste weg die ladung
zu bewegen
nach dem kurzen flug zum versorger
bringen die piloten den hubschrauber in
position er schwebt nur viereinhalb
meter über dem deck
die crew hängt die ladung an den haken
unter dem hubschrauber
sagte vorbei vorbei
angehängt
die arbeiter sind weg langsam davon
gerade hoch
auf dem rückweg zu uss busch müssen die
piloten besonders vorsichtig liegen
[Musik]
beim transport gibt es einige gefahren
und vor allem wind wenn er nicht zu
stark weht können wir alles sicher hin
und herbewegt
herrscht rückenwind muss der motor bei
der schweren ladung nicht so stark
arbeiten
dek vorarbeiter weisen den piloten die
richtige stelle zum absetzen zu
[Musik]
wir machen das so gerne weil dabei die
ganze crew zusammenarbeitet
schweben
hochziehen
runterlassen und von vorne
für die piloten reine routine
fast jede woche die munition aufstocken
damit wir weiter gegen denise kämpfen
können
als die pumpen bestandteil der ankommen
werden sie sofort einige decks tiefer
transportieren
in einen der best gesicherten bereiche
des schiffes sieben ebenen unter dem
flugdeck hier werden sie von den waffen
mechanikern in empfang genommen
zu ihnen gehört britta pickens
hier sind die bombenexperten
alle waffen des träger geschwaders
werden im magazin der uss busch gelagert
wir haben alle möglichen bomben
geschosse und raketen
die frauen und männer die hier arbeiten
sind an ihren roten hemden zu erkennen
ein wichtiger teil der mission denn ohne
waffen bräuchten wir gar nicht hier sein
die warnfarbe ruth passt zu ihrer arbeit
ein fehler und es könnte zur katastrophe
kommen
bomben gibt es nicht fertig man muss sie
zusammen bauen
und das übernehmen die rothemden
die george cabrio bus befindet sich im
persischen golf
die werfen mechaniker haben viel zu tun
sie müssen die bomben für den heutigen
einsatz gegen den sogenannten e s
zusammen bauen alle komponenten im
einzelnen so können für unterschiedliche
piloten ganz nach ihrem bedarf
vorbereiten
es gibt bomben in drei größen sie können
alles zerstören von einem kleinwagen bis
zu einem unterirdischen bunker
die grenzen liegen 230 kilo und sind
zwei meter lang
die größten bringen es auf fast vier
meter und sind 900 kilo schwer
wann sich das schiff hin und her bewegt
und eine nicht richtig festgemacht ist
könnte sie jemanden zerquetschen
ein vorfall aus der vergangenheit zeigt
welche fatalen auswirkungen ein fehler
im magazin anrichten kann
26 oktober 1966
golf von tonkin
die besatzung die uss knie bereitet sich
auf flug angriffe gegen
nordvietnamesische truppen vor
unter deck wirft ein matrose
versehentlich eine brennende signal
rakete ins waffenlager weitere fangen
feuer und es kommt zur explosion
erst nach zehn stunden ist der brand
vollständig gelöscht
[Musik]
der schaden ist enorm
drei flugzeuge zerstört
44 menschen getötet und 38 weitere
verletzt
es war das verheerende feuer auf einem
flugzeugträger seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg
50 jahre später ist der unfall immer
noch präsent
vorgaben an die wir uns halten würden
aufgrund von unfällen entwickelt
wenn ihr euch bei etwas nicht sicher
fühlt
sicherheit hat oberste priorität
nehmt euch die werkzeuge die er braucht
an einer bombe arbeiten mindestens zehn
mechaniker
wir bauen gerade eine gpu 54 dann
benutze für ziele die sich bewegen zb
wenn man ein auto treffen will
sie gehört zu so genannten jake oder
joint direkter technischen und wird
mittels gps oder laser zielsystem
gelenkt
sie ist leistungsstark und wird ziemlich
oft eingesetzt
zuerst wird die spitze montiert in ihr
befindet sich der laser sensor mit ihm
die bombe das ziel ortet nachdem sie
abgefeuert wurde das ist der 38
lasersensor
dann werden zünder und sicherung
eingebaut sie verhindert dass die bombe
bereits vor dem aufprall explodiert
ohne zünder wäre der flugkörper nur eine
über 20.000 dollar teure metallhülle
jetzt fehlt nur noch ein entscheidender
teil das navigations module es steuert
die bombe ins programmierte ziel
ohne pickens und ihre kollegen hätten
die uss bush dem sogenannten die es
nichts entgegenzusetzen
meine aufgabe ist es dem piloten eine
hochwertige bombe zur verfügung zu
stellen die dann explodiert
in nur wenigen stunden fertig das team
zehn james
und schickt sie mit einem der vier
waffen aufzüge hoch zum flugdeck
dort lädt ein zweites team an waffen
mechanikern sie in die flugzeuge
insgesamt bewegen sie mehrere hundert
kilo an bomben und raketen
die anspannung bei der beladung ist groß
ein fehler könnte die gesamte mission
gefährden
eine halbe stunde bis zum start die
flugzeuge sind bereit
doch die piloten können nicht einfach
abheben wann sie wollen
auf dem flugdeck herrscht reger verkehr
bei laufendem flugbetrieb wimmelt es
hier von dutzenden flugzeugen und
mehreren hundert menschen
die piloten müssen auf ein signal von
einem der 15 boden lotsen warten
einer von ihnen ist petty officer scott
henderson
es geht sehr hektisch zu man steht
ständig unter strom
man rennt herum und muss ich dann doch
auf dem flugdeck lauern zahlreiche
gefahren
heiße abgase laufende propeller und
rotoren und
triebwerke die einen blitzschnell
einsaugen können
die uss george hw bush liegt 800
kilometer vor der iranischen küste
22 c hawk-eye bereiten sich auf den
start vor
diese früh waren flugzeuge unterstützen
eine gruppe f a 18 bei ihren
luftangriffen auf stellungen des
sogenannten es
auf dem flugdeck versuchen 300
besatzungsmitglieder 30 jets und mehrere
hubschrauber sich nicht gegenseitig in
die quere zu kommen
neben einem flugzeug zu stehen und seine
kraft zu spüren ist
einer hat alles im blick der airbus
auf der uss busch ist das commander
chemie slawinski
spitzname
kazinsky und sein team arbeiten in einem
kleinen raum ganz oben in der insel
hier befindet sich die haupt
flugkontrolle
sie ist der logenplatz auf dem schiff
wir haben einen tollen blick auf das
heck
weselsky sind alle 550 mann der flug
abteilung untersteht der größten
abteilung an bord
sie überwacht jede phase des
flugbetriebs
einige arbeiten im hangar und bereiten
die flugzeuge auf den kampfeinsatz vor
mehr als die hälfte sind auf dem
flugdeck
uns bei dem alles klar
jetzt dreht sich alles um den start
wissen wir wo alle flugzeuge sind
die nummern stellen wieder ein
ski ist dafür verantwortlich dass alles
reibungslos abläuft
mit seinem team legt er die bewegungen
jedes einzelnen flugzeugs vor seinem
start fest
die 200 kaputt dass ich das schon einen
boden nutzer angesehen hat er okay hier
kommt nie langeweile auf
der flugplan ändert sich bewegungen der
flugzeuge erinnern sich maschinen werden
in letzter minute ausgetauscht
der airbus und sein team können sich
nicht um alles kümmern
drei etagen unter ihnen auch der
untersten ebene der insel befindet sich
die flugkontrolle
wir behalten die mitarbeiter jedes
einzelne flugzeug auf dem schiff im auge
das kommando hat der flugzeugabfertiger
sie hat bereits über 30 jahre erfahrung
auf see
ich koordiniere das flugzeug und den
hangar und sorge dafür dass flugzeuge
repariert aufgetankt und bewaffnet werde
während der kampfeinsätze ist im hangar
und auf dem flugdeck am meisten los
im großen bereich managed und ständig
jemand was von dir
täglich koordinieren mackie und sein
team über 200 starts und landungen
jede muss problemlos über die bühne
gehen
wenn nur ein jet verspätung hat gerät
der gesamte flugplan außer kontrolle
den überblick zu behalten ist nicht
einfach besonders wenn man kaum etwas
sieht
durch die paar fenster kann ich ungefähr
sehen was auf dem flugdeck so los ist
darüber hinaus verwenden mackie und
seine kollegen ein altbewährtes
hilfsmittel
das ist das keyboard es ist ein modell
des flugzeugs zu behalten wir den
überblick über das gesamte ehring
geschwader
die winzigen modelle zeigen wo sich ein
flugzeug auf dem flugdeck oder im hangar
befindet verschiedenen muttern und bunte
reißnägeln geben auskunft darüber was
die maschine braucht bevor sie starten
kann die modelle sind maßstabsgetreue
sie tragen die nummern der richtigen
flugzeuge und stehen genau dort wo der
flugzeuge sind so können wir sehen ob
sie betankt oder berechnet werden müssen
oder sonst
in unserer digitalen welt wirkt es
vielleicht veraltet doch computer können
ausfallen dass die geburt nicht
es gibt eine elektronische variante
das wort benutzt delay wie seit
jahrzehnten tut immer noch seinen dienst
menger
15 minuten bis zum abflug mecki wird vom
airbus angefunkt zeit die einsatztruppe
auf position zu bringen
verstanden wir gehen raus und fangen an
die flugzeuge zu bewegen
nike hat zwar das kommando
aber die crew auf dem flug der cut die
eigentliche arbeit
die erfordert kraft
und nerven wie drahtseile
1991 ein matrose hat einen a6 intruder
ein katapult eines flugzeugträgers ein
er gerät zu nah an eins der triebwerke
und wird eingesaugt
wie durch ein wunder bleibt er hängen
bevor er in die schaufelräder gerät er
überlebte nahezu unverletzt
auf dem flugdeck ist es nirgendwo sicher
der pilot eines t zwei bagger verschätzt
sich bei der landung
er und vier weitere matrosen sterben
17 weitere
als schwer verletzt
innerhalb von 12 sekunden ist das
rettungsteam vor ort nach zwei minuten
hat es den brand unter kontrolle
die crew hat diese unfälle bei jedem
start im hinterkopf doch das ist nicht
die einzige belastung
wir müssen 27 tonnen schweren flugzeugen
ausweichen
und den ohrenbetäubenden lärm aushalten
laut
die bodenlosen verwenden eine ganz
eigene sprache um die flugzeuge
einzuweisen alles so laut ist müssen wir
handzeichen geben
[Musik]
das erste flugzeug darf zum katapult
das winken ist das zeichen für den
piloten mit dem rangieren zu beginnen
danach gibt der boden lotse die
kontrolle über das flugzeug an einen
anderen kollegen in gelben hemd ab er
hat einen der wichtigsten jobs auf dem
flugdeck der schulden
wir sind für einen sicheren start und
eine sichere landung verantwortlich
heute sind lieutenant von corny und drei
weitere kollegen im dienst
drei der shooter arbeiten auf dem deck
carney ist in der catapult
kontrollstation genannt die blase
die blase ist ein kleiner raum der enns
flug decke eingelassen ist ein sicherer
ort von dem der leitende shooter der
restlichen crew anweisungen geben kann
an land stehen für start und landung bis
zu zweieinhalb kilometer zur verfügung
auf einem flugzeugträger sind des
höchstens 120 meter
um auf so kurzer strecke zu starten
braucht das flugzeug extraschub
lösung ein katapult
ist ein flugzeug bereit zum start rollt
es zum katapult
die crew an deck verbindet das vorderrad
mit dem schlitten
der schlitten ist der teil des carports
der mit dem flugzeug verbunden hat
jetzt beginnt carneys arbeit
zuerst lässt er das katapult kurz
anziehen
dabei setzen wir das hydraulische system
unter strom und halten das flugzeug in
position
während cani das katapult vorbereitet
nimmt die crew hinter dem flugzeug eine
wichtige schutzmaßnahme vor einen gas
strahl abweiser die wand schützt die
matrosen vor den heißen abgasen des jets
diese flugzeuge stoßen jede menge heiße
abgase aus wenn sie über das flugdeck
rasen
der pilot im ersten jet nimmt die
letzten checks vor um sicher zu gehen
dass seine maschine startklar ist
dann gibt der vollen schub so viel wie
ohne wenn er möglich ist
und
mit dem boss hoss
der salut des piloten an die decke
signalisiert carney dass er bereit ist
denkste
die f a 18 kommt in drei sekunden von
null auf 240
[Musik]
wie immer kurz schickt die crew einen
flieger nach dem anderen
mit vier katapulten bringen die alle 30
bis 45 sekunden ein flugzeug in die luft
das flugdeck ist einer der krassesten
auto und denen ich je gearbeitet habe
am anfang war es für mich das reinste
chaos aber je länger man hier ist desto
mehr gewöhnt man sich dran der mama
kapiert hat wie es läuft erkennt man
in weniger als zehn minuten sind alle f
a 18 gestartet und auf dem weg nach
syrien
es ist toll wie reibungslos alles läuft
selbst nach einem erfolgreichen start
macht sich die crew auf dem flugdeck
gedanken über die sicherheit der piloten
sie müssen schließlich auch noch landen
sobald wir alle in die luft gebracht
haben bereiten mir schon alles für die
landung vor
du hast ja wieder auf
noch befinden sich die kampfflugzeuge
der uss bush im einsatz
doch eineinhalb stunden später denkt
jeder mitarbeiter der flug abteilung nur
an eines seht ihr schon was
sie wieder sicher an bord zu bringen
auf einer belebten schwimmenden
landebahn aufzusetzen ist eine
herausforderung
ja da oben ist noch einer
da drüben
beobachtet den luftraum in einem umkreis
von acht kilometern um den
flugzeugträger
er gibt den piloten die reihenfolge für
die landung durch klar und deutlich
10 hornet und super hornet flieger
kreisen über dem schiff und warten
darauf landen zu dürfen
kosinski kann sie unmöglich alle im auge
behalten deswegen hat der verstärkung
22.07 wir landen durch den minibus
commander mark cent
wir kontrollieren etwa 180 grad des
luftraums der hier vor uns liegt
und beobachtet den bereich vor dem
schiff
gesehen ski den dahinter
beide wissen wie schwierig es ist auf
einem flugzeugträger zu landen sie sind
auch piloten
ich stelle von hier aus sicher dass die
flugzeugen von dort bis nach da hinten
kommen im richtigen abstand getaktet
werden um gefahrlos zu lang
kazinsky kontrolliert noch mal das deck
und gibt an die lande freigabe für die
erste elf
jetzt übernehmen die lande signal
offiziere kurz lsa
heute ist ihr leiter lieutenant john
boomen
die letzten 1200 meter bis zur landung
sind die eso für die einweisung der
piloten verantwortlich
wir sind bei mehring angestellt und die
flugzeuge sich herunterzuladen
auf dem flugdeck eines trägers gibt es
keinen spielraum für fehler
die piloten bleiben nur gut 100 meter
das gefährlichste ist die kurze
landebahn
die f a 18 piloten fahren ihre funhouse
ohne geht's nicht
mit ihnen müssen sie einen von drei
stahlseilen erwischen die über das
flugdeck gespannt sind die
aufgabe der eso ist es die piloten so
anzuleiten dass sie einst der seile zu
fassen bekommen
lande signal offiziere sind auf einem
flugzeugträger unentbehrlich und waren
es schon immer
die uss langley markiert den beginn
eines neuen zeitalters
sie ist der erste flugzeugträger der usa
[Musik]
die marine luftfahrt steckt noch in den
kinderschuhen
[Musik]
um zu landen gleiten die piloten die
holzplanken des decks entlang und
versuchen 1 der 15-fache säule auf der
langley zu erwischen
sie können sich nur auf ihre augen und
ihr glück verlassen um es sicher an bord
zu schaffen
es wird schnell klar ein besseres system
muss her
[Musik]
bei einem anflug schnappt sich ein
gewiefter matrose zwei stück stoff und
gibt dem piloten damit anweisungen für
eine sichere landung
[Musik]
seitdem gibt es den lande signal
offizieren
ihre lorbeeren verdienen sich die im
zweiten weltkrieg und sie bekommen einen
spitznamen
[Musik]
die paddel
wegen der paddel
die piloten hinunter wähnten
[Musik]
bald gibt es sie auf jedem flug deck
seit 1955 haben sie ein hilfsmittel ein
optisches lande hilfssystem auch mit
ball genannt
der meat ball ist ein orangefarbenes
licht das den piloten anzeigt ob sie
sich im richtigen anflugwinkel befinden
sie können es aus zweieinhalb kilometern
entfernung sehen
[Musik]
wenn der mieter sich in einer kette von
grünen licht an einreiht ist der winkel
korrekt
liegt er darunter ist das flugzeug zu
niedrig
färbt sich das licht ruht wird es
gefährlich
[Applaus]
wo man muss sicherstellen dass die
piloten in nied bohlen in den letzten 15
bis 18 flug sekunden gut sehen können
der pilot um die ecke kommt
signalisierte er dass sie das licht
sieht
die lsv stehen als zusätzliche hilfe
bereit
der erste pilot ist 15 km vom schiff
entfernt er gibt den tower eine wichtige
information durch
das gewicht seiner f a 18
wir einstellungen müssen zu ihrem
gewicht lassen damit sie in der
richtigen geschwindigkeit abgebremst
wird sicher zum stehen kommt
das machen wir für jedes einzelne
flugzeug das land wird
wenn der jet nähert wird die ab
bremsvorrichtung auf sein gewicht
programmiert die maschinen unter deck
stellen dann die richtige bremskraft für
die fan meile 1
der 1
bilder
15 sekunden später ist die f a 18 kurz
vor dem schiff
doch das bewegt sich zu stark um sicher
landen zu können
die erde so signalisieren einen neuen
versuch
eine minute später versucht der pilot
ist noch mal
[Musik]
es sieht gut aus
fehlt das sein
wenn er das sei verfehlt muss er
abbrechen durchstarten und das noch mal
drei landeversuche kommen nicht oft vor
der pilot erhält die ungeteilte
aufmerksamkeit der gesamten flug
abteilungen
[Musik]
ob er es schafft hängt auch von ihnen ab
die f a 18 dreht noch eine runde und
beginnt erneut mit dem landeanflug
selbst wenn sie jetzt aufsetzt kann noch
etwas schiefgehen
zum beispiel mit der ab bremsvorrichtung
insgesamt 10 f a 18 super hornet
kern von ihrem einsatz zu uss bush
zurück
die crew-mitglieder
warten auf die landung der ersten
maschine
doch es läuft nicht immer nach plan
déi 2 hawk eye
auf der uss eisenhower zu landen
sie erwischt das fach sein doch das
kabel zerreißt
flugzeug ist nicht mehr zu sehen
aber der pilot kann es wieder hochziehen
und startet einen zweiten versuch
acht besatzungsmitglieder werden durch
das gerissene kabel schwer verletzt
egal wie gut wir vorbereitet sind es
kann immer noch jemand zur falschen zeit
am falschen ort sein
wir tun alles dass niemandem etwas
passiert
die erste f a 18 versucht ein drittes
mal zu landen
dieses mal erwischt der pilot 1 der
seile
die 18 tonnen schwere maschine kommt
nach zwei sekunden zum stehen
die crew muss in weniger als einer
minute die landebahn räume
in dem bereich in dem die waffen
entladen
dann dirigieren sie ihn nach vorne oder
hinten je nachdem wie es auf dem
flugdeck
[Musik]
vielen dank
nun können auch die neuen an
[Musik]
vor wenigen minuten ist die gesamte
einsatztruppe sicher zurück und
für heute ist schluss
doch morgen beginnt alles wieder von
vorne
[Musik]
das team arbeitet jeden tag sehr gut und
eng zusammen
wir lieben unsere arbeit
sie ist unsere leidenschaft
es ist ein privileg jeden tag hier oben
zu stehen
[Musik]
hinter jedem piloten der zu einem
kampfeinsatz aufbricht
steht ein schiff voller matrosen
die koordiniert
entschlossen
und engagierte arbeit
sie
sorgen dafür dass die flugzeuge
funktionieren damit wir rausfliegen
können
wenn man sich nicht gegenseitig vertraut
kann man es gleich lassen
egal auf welchem deck oder in welcher
abteilung sie arbeiten
die frauen und männer auf der uss bush
sind ein team und jeder job ist wichtig
für die mission kultur mit
jena matrose wird gebraucht damit die
flugzeuge starten und wir geben unsere
feinde vorgehen können allein darum geht
es
wir tun alles um die bad guys zu
besiegen
flugzeug statt
wenn man sich die anzahl der flugzeuge
anschauung alles drumherum ist das schon
ziemlich klasse
und landungen
immer wieder
tag für tag
es ist schön zu sehen wie alles
aufeinander abgestimmt ist
sie sei eine symphonie der leist in
seinen teilung des medienhafens das ist
das tolle daran
das team ist stolz darauf
ja
[Musik]
auf einem der größten kriegsschiffe der
welt zu arbeiten
uss george hw bush